[Musica]
buonasera a tutti grazie
invito dire che sono emozionate poco che
in immaginatelo da soli io sono un
oncologo e ho trascorso tutta la vita a
combattere ogni giorno contro il cancro
e contro l'indifferenza
sono nato in un piccolo paese
dell'appennino tosco emiliano
esattamente a corniolo e di santa sofia
dove quando qualcuno ammalava di tumore
il paese ammutoliva ammutoliva e
subentrava una specie di lutto un lutto
che anticipava poi la morte vera questo
mi impressionava moltissimo e un giorno
mia madre mi chiede ma tu però di fare
da grande e io dissi voglio curare
quella malattia li e risposi
e così diventa i oncologo la mia
attività che si svolge ovviamente in
romagna ha però voluto guardare oltre e
mi sono subito interessato di un
problema enorme che è quello della
problematica del cancro nell'africa sub
sahariana e così mi sono dedicato
all'attività risulterò in tanzania la
tanzania fa parte dell'africa
subshariana un'area diseredata dove come
possiamo vedere adesso il cancro non è
così assente l'africa partecipa per il 6
per cento al tasso globale di tumori nel
mondo
ma questo è ancora poco quello che è
importante sapere è che il cancro in
quel paese significa morte
praticamente fra l'incidenza accesso ai
nuovi casi che si sviluppano ogni anno i
casi che muoiono c'è una differenza
minima le mentre invece come vedete in
questa slide nei paesi ad alto sviluppo
tecnologico più del 60 per cento delle
persone guarisce quindi intanto c'è
questo dato tremendo ma l'altro dato
ancora più impressionante è che mentre
negli anni 70 il cancro di quel paese
del 15 per cento di tutte le malattie
oggi
è il 60 per cento e si prevede che nel
2030 possa arrivare anche al 70 per
cento e quello che è ancora più grave è
più preoccupante è che l'organizzazione
mondiale della sanità prevede che nel
2030 la mortalità per cancro aumenti nel
mondo di 5 milioni ogni anno
bene di questi 5 milioni ogni anno 4
milioni proverranno dai paesi in via di
sviluppo dove purtroppo non esistono le
condizioni per un controllo di questa
malattia
quello che è sconcertante e anche che i
media si sono dimenticati del problema è
soltanto nel 2013 sono comparsi articoli
sui giornali importanti che segnalano
come questo big killer che è il cancro
stia occupando un paese intero un'area
intera di milioni di abitanti senza che
vi siano mezzi per contro batterlo e
inoltre anche la politica stessa e ha
trascurato il tema tant'è vero che
soltanto nel 2011 in occasione di una
dichiarazione dell'assemblea generale
delle nazioni unite si è appreso si è
presa coscienza del tema e sia
cominciato a pensare di dover fare
qualcosa e ecco che l'organizzazione
africana contro il cancro si chiama
aortic ha iniziato a diffondere questa
problematica nel paese e io sono rimasto
sconvolto quando tre anni fa al
congresso mondiale della orti che si è
svolta a durban in sudafrica è venuto
fuori questo quesito ma diagnosticare il
cancro ha senso dove non ci sono i mezzi
per curarlo
immaginate quale tipo di quesito sia
questo
ma la risposta non può essere altro che
ha senso perché noi dobbiamo fare il
possibile perché anche in quel
territorio che siano le possibilità di
curare questa malattia
ed ecco che ho pensato abbiamo pensato
con alcuni partner di fare questo
progetto un progetto che si prefigge di
fare un'attività di controllo del cancro
a monza monza è una città della tanzania
e il pil il diciamo il motivo per cui io
mi sono mosso in questa direzione
fondando un'associazione che si chiama e
vittorio tucson è stata l'amicizia con
questo collega questo collega che
patologo prima a faenza e poi a cesena è
morto per un melanoma nel 1995 in sua
memoria e per onorarlo io ho messo in
piedi un'associazione che appunto è
intervenuta a mwanza muanda è una città
dell'africa sub sahariana dove è
collocata sulle rive del lago vittoria
dove esiste una percentuale di tumori
molto elevata il tumori sono la seconda
causa di morte dopo tutte le altre
malattie infettive e non esistono non
esistevano nel 2000 alcun non aveva
alcuna possibilità di cura di diagnosi e
di controllo 0
non c'è la consapevolezza di questa
malattia pensate che la malattia cancro
veniva ritenuta una malattia contagiosa
bene in questa città c'è poi questo
ospedale bugando medical center che è un
ospedale gr un grosso ospedale dove sono
ricoverati prevalentemente pazienti
affetti da malaria tubercolosi e aids
io in quell'ospedale nel 2002 grazie ai
fondi della associazione teson ho potuto
realizzare un laboratorio un laboratorio
dell'autonomia patologica che era
totalmente assente
questo laboratorio oggi è un laboratorio
pienamente funzionante totalmente
gestito dai dai colleghi locali un
criterio fondamentale se si vuole
intervenire utilmente in questo paese è
creare li delle realtà le quali si
mantengano nel tempo e rappresentino il
catalizzatore della presa di coscienza
del problema dove operino i
professionisti preparati qualificati
formatisi nelle migliori università del
mondo
e successivamente al laboratorio di
anatomia patologica
abbiamo fatto un altra cosa nel momento
in cui ho preso coscienza di questa
realtà mi sono reso conto che in africa
c'è una quantità di tumori
incredibilmente alta soprattutto nei
bambini soprattutto nei bambini fra 0 e
14 anni sono tutti i tumori
prevalentemente legate alle forme
infettive di quel paese e che potrebbero
guarire quasi tutti se curati
adeguatamente è scattato
ovviamente un imperativo categorico non
si può di fronte a questa realtà a
rimanere così inerti rimanere
indifferenti ed ecco che dopo che ho
portato un collega tanzanese a formarsi
nell'istituto per cinque anni e dopo che
questo collega acquisito la specialità
in oncologia unico oncologo medico
tanzanese il dottor nestor i masaru che
qui vedete con me in un congresso
dell'aiom italiana
abbiamo stretto con il ministero della
salute un progetto il progetto oncologia
che prevede prevenzione assistenza
interventi in quel settore ricerca e
formazione
con questo progetto siamo riusciti a
realizzare una struttura di oncologia
medica che è completamente nuova
pensate che in tanzania in
quell'ospedale presso il bugando medical
center fino al 2008 pazienti affetti da
cancro curati e datati nessuno oggi a
sette anni di distanza
abbiamo ben 24 mila casi di soggetti
ammalati di cancro curati in quella
realtà abbiamo supportato l'attività
locale ma basando soprattutto sui locali
sui medici locali sugli infermieri
locali sui tecnici locali
l'attività dell'istituzione abbiamo
supportato questa istituzione con
oncologi italiani volontari molti di
questi
e abbiamo anche fatto qualcos'altro
ogni anno forniamo a questa realtà i
farmaci per la durata di un anno che
dovete sapere che oltre tutto lì i
malati devono pagarsi le cure se
vogliono curarsi io ho visto delle
famiglie vendere la mucca venderla
capretta per poter stare in ospedale a
curarsi il tumore
poi abbiamo anche portato tecnologie
molto importanti e e abbiamo pensato
anche cose molto importante ridurre il
carico di tumore in che modo riducendone
l'incidenza e come si fa per fare questo
la cosa migliore è fare diagnosi precoce
per i tumori dell'utero della mammella
pensate che il 53 per cento delle morti
per cause per per tumore nella donna
sono dovute al cancro della cervice
uterina che nei paesi sviluppati non
colpi non uccide più nessuno
praticamente le donne sono accorse
numerosissime e con grande entusiasmo a
questo progetto
poi ultima realizzazione
io sono stato al ministero della salute
tanzanese è libero è molto importante
questo bisogna lavorare in accordo con
le istituzioni non bisogna presentarsi
come dei colonizzatori e rappresentarsi
come dei servitori che vanno lì per dare
una mano e il ministero della salute mi
ha ricevuto ha capito il problema e ha
investito milioni di euro per realizzare
questa struttura che è una struttura per
la radioterapia la radioterapia
nell'area sub sahariana e non è
disponibile per più di 150 milioni di
abitanti
oggi già funziona una cobaltoterapia è
anche una brachiterapia e questo
acceleratore lineare che ne abbia
mandato da forlì già due anni fa è
ancora lì è ancora lì impacchettato però
sono sicuro che questo sarà l'anno nel
quale verrà verrà messo in piedi
funzionanti
e quando il the lancet oncology ha
pubblicato nel 2013 un articolo dove
diceva quello che si sarebbe dovuto fare
in africa per favorire il controllo del
cancro noi abbiamo avuto la
soddisfazione di pubblicare il nostro
progetto che prevedeva e ha realizzato
tutto ciò che veniva suggerito dalla
scienza ufficiale questa fotografia mi
fa venire in mente una storia importante
che io ho sofferto molto fra i bambini
che noi abbiamo curato c'era un bambino
un ragazzino che si chiamava pandu gli
panduri aveva un linfoma trattato
localmente con chemioterapia portato
quasi alla guarigione seno che ci voleva
ancora un trattamento un trattamento
radioterapico la radioterapia come avete
visto era assente un mio collaboratore
che aveva fatto il volontario l'ha
portato a milano sperando di poterlo
anche trattenere il bambino a milano non
si è adattato è diventato irritabile
quasi violento per cui al termine della
terapia radiante con la quale guarito il
bambino è tornato a casa e sono andato a
trovarlo un anno dopo
ho trovato un fanciullo un ragazzo
eccezionale felice sereno
studiava già tre lingue un ragazzo che
si prospettava in un futuro radioso e
sono stato ben felice di salutarlo è
venuto con la bicicletta che io gli
avevo regalato un anno prima per farmi
vedere quanto fosse grato
dopo altri alcuni mesi sono tornato in
tanzania
amanda ho chiesto al dottor masaro di
farmi votare pandozy panucci non c'era
più era morto era morto non del tumore
era morto per una pugnalata ricevuta in
una rissa fra bambini di strada
potete immaginare lo sconforto
l'amarezza che io ho provato perché lì è
la società che è malata società povera
una società malata di ignoranza ed
arretratezza di superstizione di
abbandono e quindi è quasi inutile
si potrebbe dire ma non lo è fare tanto
per le singole persone per non curare
poi quella società
d'altra parte l'unico modo è quello di
fare aumentare la cultura la
preparazione e noi abbiamo organizzato
una serie di convegni e soprattutto di
corsi per medici e oggi abbiamo in un
convegno fatto quindici giorni fa tre
settimane fa ha avuto il piacere aver
ben 110 medici del territorio tanzanese
monzese che hanno partecipato con grande
con grande volontà di apprendere e di
divulgare divulgare il problema allora
cosa dire di fronte a un tema che il
papa ha recentemente messo in evidenza
l'indifferenza non bisogna avere
indifferenza verso queste cose
l'indifferenza una malattia lui ha detto
la malattia più grave che affligge i
nostri tempi bisogna combatterla come
bisogna combatterla prendendo coscienza
singolarmente di questi problemi e
offrire ai a coloro che hanno bisogno la
nostra umanità la nostra intelligenza la
nostra carità ma anche verso i popoli
c'è bisogno di prendere coscienza di
questo e bisogna che i grandi paesi
occidentali sviluppi in un programma
globale di assistenza di sviluppo di
quei paesi affinché grazie a questo
intervento possano uscire da quella vita
che non è dignitosa e infine e concludo
ricordiamoci che c'è bisogno sicuramente
di un nuovo umanesimo un nuovo umanesimo
che riesca permeare individui popoli
istituzioni dell'unico valore che può
dare un sollievo ai guai che
l'indifferenza produce in queste società
malate e sofferenti la solidarietà
[Applauso]